eu vou fechar de impotência falta de
esperança e solidão famílias que cuidam
de crianças com epilepsia se sentem
impotentes sem esperança e sozinhas e um
projeto que passe pela Microsoft
identificamos uma maneira de ajudar os
médicos a reduzir o número EA gravidade
de convulsões em crianças com epilepsia
aí de trazer a esperança aos cuidadores
e fazer com que suas famílias não se
sintam sozinhos
Oi Vitor o caminho que estejamos
preparados ia também pode ser repetido
para outras doenças e o resultado dessa
pesquisa pode capacidade de hoje
cuidadores e médicos e todo mundo esse
trabalho inspirado em italiano de 10
anos chamado marido antes ele não acende
Alegre 2011 e dez dias eu posso pato ele
teve um AVC que afetou quarenta por
cento do seu cérebro nem tô perdido no
Chicago paralisia cerebral processo de
aplicação foi fácil com inúmeras visitas
a diferença especialistas e muita
frustração faz o gato grande Francisca
fidele inclusive compartilhar
experiência e o famoso da história
chamado da doença do nosso PB uma lição
de vida vai muito a pena né a propósito
o horário também trabalho a Microsoft
nós fazemos parte do time de
acessibilidade e temos a missão de poder
a pessoas com deficiências através de
tecnologias assistivas põe a vida do
casal mudou drasticamente quando lá e
completou 4 anos
a vida ele teve uma confusão
generalizada e foi diagnosticado com
epilepsia focal do mar a condições
acontece durante a noite dos Pais ficou
acordar a cirurgia todas as madrugadas
o estresse a dormir ou dormir mal mais
cedo e
e como configurar futebol Ele disse que
as convulsões do Windows o atendente mas
a preocupação com a próxima convulsão
vice-prefeito constantemente
e com consequências imprevisíveis
acontecer o tempo todo o tempo para
fazer volume reabilitação casal decidiu
criar a fundação fato de troca para
ajudar curadores como eles Deixa então
ele posto resposta para a seguinte
pergunta como reduzir a frequência EA
gravidade das condições em crianças com
epilepsia pertencia é a quatro doença
neurológica mais comum afetando mais de
65 milhões de pessoas e todo mundo e é
caracterizado por convulsões
imprevisíveis existem vários tipos de
condições e o controle com medicamentos
varia de pessoa para pessoa
e as pessoas não têm acesso a
medicamento especialmente em países em
desenvolvimento onde a maioria vive
falta de informação sobre o assunto pode
causar desafios emocionais e saúde 500
vezes são piores do que as próprias
conclusões
o acesso uma pessoa compreensiva morre
durante ou após uma convulsão sem motivo
e o risco de morte prematura pessoa com
epilepsia é até três vezes maior do que
para a população geral igual as
convulsões da epilepsia posso estar
relacionadas a uma lesão cerebral como o
caso do Maio uma tendência familiar
muitas vezes a causa é completamente
desconhecida nem cada quatro pessoas com
paralisia cerebral e uma em cada cinco
pessoas com autismo tem epilepsia a
gente afetar pessoas com a série de
outras deficiências a comoção pode
afetar qualquer parte do corpo e os
eventos elétricos que produzem os
sintomas ocorrem no cérebro
e para pesquisa sobre a epilepsia são
fragmentadas com o serviço prestado
sucessivos e falta de acesso e ficado de
informação para análise tendência de
dados naviskauto cada paciente é único
EA família são frequentemente forçadas a
escolher entre totais convencionais que
geralmente são mais vocês não é mas pode
também não atender melhor necessidade do
paciente ou então assumir o risco com
possibilidade ainda não testados que
poderia funcionar melhor mas os pais e
seus cuidadores estão sob constante
estresse com Tim e a ansiedade confusão
perguntas difíceis de algumas perguntas
como esse é o filho te dar uma convulsão
enquanto dorme seu filho estiver sozinho
tiver uma condução
e quais são os gatinhos que aumenta o
risco da condução e se esqueça de dar
medicamento qual o impacto da dieta
medicação estresse que eu tinha ninguém
me convulsão hoje infelizmente no as
respostas Claras para essas perguntas
em situações estressantes impacta a vida
a saúde eo bem-estar de todos ao redor
da vida familiar e ajustada para muitas
vezes acomodar as necessidades do
paciente isso pode resultar em decisões
desafiadores de vida como modificação
pelo emprego mudança promulgar
implicações financeiras significativas
depressão privação de solo em alguns
casos perda de relacionamento por mais
de divórcio
e depois já estávamos com times para o
mundo enquanto profissionais de outros
países eu vou gato não podia viajar ele
tem que estar por perto para ajudar
e como reduzir a frequência EA gravidade
das condições de crianças com epilepsia
o cliente não tinha multidisciplinar de
várias áreas da Microsoft em quantas
designers Engenheiros de software e
profissionais de marketing de diversas
especialidades serviu para criar uma
solução de monitoramento remoto chamada
mil e tirar esse sistema coleta de dados
biométricos e contextuais para fornecer
tratamento personalizado para cada
criança auxiliar médicos e diagnósticos
precisos esse projeto foi o vencedor do
Microsoft rápido 2019 iniciativa anual
da Microsoft que Visa apoiar projetos de
inovação social mais sete mil forjados
no nosso escolhido aí de gás vaca Então
vamos também premiados com problema de
residência em colaboração com a
Microsoft por um instante durante seis
meses tive o privilégio de trabalhar
integralmente continha especializado em
tecnologia de ponta com objetivo de
transformar o protótipo queremos um ato
provar condição mínima de viabilidade
nesse período tivemos oportunidade de
conhecer 172 só meses e 23 país
em várias partes do Brasil com profundo
senso de empatia temos uma falta
comodidade para e com as famílias com
cresce complexidade e fomos aconselhados
por médicos e especialistas nessa área
Olá pessoal Espero que eu vou não
amizade é tudo Nossa pessoa que notícia
é que eu não durmo também o meu filho na
minha cama durante a noite faço isso
desde que ele era recém-nascido mas
agora que tem seis anos e tem mais duas
conduções por dia algumas acontece
durante a noite essa situação criou
muitos problemas e cuidando de voz e
problemas de relacionamento com a minha
família ligação social no trabalho na
escola também está comprometida nada
disso não é fácil
é importante para mim foi pai e filho
branca e faz perguntas sobre nossas
intenções com os dados coletados
perguntas relacionadas à privacidade
segurança ele tava muito preocupado na
região inclusive os pylon cá as
convulsões epilépticas são considerados
Conceição de espiritual por questões
culturais e também crenças antigas
crianças e famílias Elas podem até ser
assassinadas sem descobertas
a vontade de assistir por isso é uma
ameaça para a segurança deles
a moto história dos Estados Unidos não é
iniciado e mostrou uma blusa branca na
parede do quarto do filho quando uma
convulsão acontecia para fazer uma vaca
e Registro identifica no tipo da
condução em qual dia ocorreu cada duas
semanas lá tirar uma foto e mandar uma
foto para o médico da família ela também
imprimir é sete páginas de um arquivo
Excel onde ela ela quer passeava a
medicação do filho garante que as doses
fossem corretas fossem dadas no tempo
certo que não acontecesse erro de dar a
mesma medicação duas vezes então deles
eram 15 medicamentos durante o dia e os
medicamentos que mudaram depende da
semana de vez
a cada família paciência de veículos que
conversamos de todos os continentes se
partes do planeta nós consultamos um
mesmo sentimento de impotência falta de
esperança e solidão
e os médicos também não é fácil os
médicos tem que confiar nos pais para
dar os medicamentos certos nas 12 setas
e na hora certa e isso é difícil pois
Muitas vezes os pais estão estressados e
com muitas responsabilidades
a apoiar paciência remotamente sem dados
e sai é um fio logo no começo dos pés
uma dá uma família de Cingapura
questionou porque o batimento cardíaco
do fixo dia logo após as 8 horas da
noite perto da hora de dormir aí nossa
colheita elas pra que a pessoa população
Especialista com batidas informação que
aliás tinha sido detectada com a nossa
solução de monitoramento e dois dias
depois ela retornou com organizado na
contou pra gente que o remédio que o
filho dela tomava causavam um aumento do
batimento cardíaco que muitas vezes
prejudicar o som com as informação
irmãos um médico outro horário começa
tarde e principalmente a qualidade de
sono reduziu com funções simples
é esse centro de outras famílias que ela
tá uma melhora na qualidade de vida
especialmente do Sono nos encorajou
dependente de projeto existências
contexto ao invés de trabalharmos uma
solução para pessoa com epilepsia
dedicamos a nossa atenção para o
ambiente para as pessoas ao redor da
criança alguém te conhecia e muito
bem-estar da criança com a inflexível
mas cansados sem dormir se uma
probabilidade maior de erradicação o
horário a dose sem contar que o ambiente
com os demais membros da família fica
comprometido Imagino que vocês já
passaram por uma experiência assim lá em
alguma ocasião Agora eu achei nessa
situação todos os dias vemos e ouvimos
essa frustração e é isso nós estamos
determinados a fazer a ponte contratos
ensaios para fornecer informações em
tempo real para médicos cuidadores
famílias e seus pacientes
se você tiver um papa Quando conhecemos
O Gabriel vai Anne seu fundador da tsf
protection plan save you o doutor
Mariane construiu o maior banco de dados
de recém-nascidos com lesões cerebrais
do número a tsf parece o atendimento
remoto a recém nascidos em 37 hospitais
no Brasil na Inglaterra LED confesso que
ver um brasileiro liderado essa
iniciativa e influenciam na universidade
de contas todo mundo me deixou muito
orgulhosa e feliz com os dados da PRF em
uma apologistas dos centros urbanos
auxílio médico de família e cuidadores
em regiões remotos com a intenção
processual e médica eles podem reduzir
drasticamente as chances de
recém-nascidos que envolver em
deficiências permanentes justamente
melões curso de saúde e seguro
é uma criança senhora são cerebral
necessita de cuidados médicos simples
como pediatra consultas médicas e
rotinas né claramente precisou ser
hospitalizado creme bater essa conversa
cerebral especialmente dois vai ser Vera
e querem ter médico multidisciplinar
filmado pediatra neurologista
ortopedista neurocirurgião
oftalmologista dentista fisioterapeuta e
fonoaudiólogos à identificação especial
uso frequente de hospitais e até a Lua
mas isso só minhas gastar quatro vezes
mais que cuidar de uma criança com
deficiência e os cursos para o sistema
de saúde também só expressivos em 2018 o
custo do governo brasileiro para
financiar benefício para pessoas com
deficiência foi o próximo de 30 bilhões
de reais
e o social e econômico para assistir uma
criança como se tivesse complicações
neurológicas como a epilepsia é
devastador é
o PSF do trabalho Eliane tem como
metodologias que reduzem o risco de
lesões permanentes e bebês e
recém-nascidos uma das técnicas se eu
ligo acho fascinante é de resfriamento
da temperatura corpórea após a lesão
geralmente em dois Krause meio Celsius
conhecimento do corpo metabolismo
inflamação são reduzidas na região
afetada diminuído drasticamente as
possíveis consequências da Visão mais
interessante esse sistema de apoio à
Criança com lesão cerebral e
oferecimento escala na tela está em
medicina e o monitoramento remoto
profissionais especializados Oriente
médicos e família em hospitais e ritmos
remotos coletânea interpretando
informações em tempo real ao estado
Centro de Atendimento em São Paulo como
é que fascinado ao ver várias telas com
informações e vídeos em tempo real de
bebezinhos de várias partes do Brasil e
do mundo
o curso tecnologia da novo combinado com
soluções inteligência artificial tem
permitido resultados promissores com
obtenção de convulsões em bebês que
antes não eram possíveis identificar
e faz isso os dados gerados criam
possibilidades de Interpretação da
informação mas quatro mil bebês 270 mil
horas de monitoramento e 40 mil
internações em tempo real já estão ali
para fazer altos um futuro espera-se
identificar uma possível conversão antes
mesmo dela correr na pesquisa o projeto
caminhar neste sentido
Tá combinado nossos telefones minha
Richard PSF podemos ajudar os familiares
cuidadores de crianças com influencia
desde o nascimento até a vida adulta
continuaremos monitorando os sinais
vitais após a saída da criança do
hospital gerando mais dados para Ciência
e Pesquisa em que estamos fortemente que
esse caminho também pode ser aplicado
para outras doenças consegue deixar três
autorizados desse trabalho primeiro
aprendizado é importância da empatia na
inovação às vezes criamos soluções e
trocamos ideias sem as consultar o
convidar as pessoas que utilizam a
solução eles vão comum e é triste
constatar também que ocorre no setor de
saúde ao criados a solução de
monitoramento comum comparar os pais de
crianças com epilepsia entendemos vários
aspectos do problema tanto em questão de
saúde como também fatores emocionais e
sociais nós não podíamos excluir essas
considerações a ao criadas
o homem poderá os pais com informações e
controle interessamos o sentimento de
impotência e solidão criando condições
para um melhor bem-estar da família
Cuidar de quem cuida foi ao super idade
o segundo aprendizado foi entender a
relevância do cuidador eu fiquei
absolutamente impressionado com
conhecimento e compreensão do
diagnóstico e condição médica que cada
família de que eu ajudando e apoiando
seus dentes que isso é muito caso eu
tive a impressão de que as mães sabiam
mais sobre apreciado pelos próprios
médicos dia apenas um problema que a
informação presidente da família e era
compartilhado apenas com o médico para
mim Foi incrível que aprendizados e
perspectivas não são compartilhados
adequadamente entre famílias e partes
interessadas na saúde o sistema
simplesmente perde oportunidade de
aprender coletivamente principalmente os
especialistas que eles caçam os pais eu
vejo aqui com a Vans
o Health Tech eu já onde acredito que
uma grande transformação do sistema de
saúde pode acontecer e ainda sistema
está desatualizado e seguindo protocolos
e práticas que não faz sentido
considerando a quantidade de tecnologia
conhecer uma disponível
a ser utilizado foi entender aqui a
melhor maneira de ajudar uma pessoa para
clips ia ajudar todas as pessoas com
epilepsia adora experiência informações
atualizadas é muito Rita família se
beneficiando de pós práticas de outras
famílias de outros sistemas saúde e até
de outras culturas sem contar que essa
interação endereça os principais
sentimentos negativos da sua doença que
a solidão
É sim é possível reduzir o número EA
gravidade das condições Esperamos que
esse projeto tava esperança e adultos
sentimentos de impotência e sua idosos
famílias Muito obrigado